- [Narrator] This half gallon
of whole milk from Aldi
costs $2.18 cents,
eggs 1.87, bread 1.29.
(gentle music)
Aldi is the fastest-growing grocer
by store count in the country,
and its no-frills approach
has also made it one of the cheapest.
(trolley thudding)
For the past decade,
it's been growing at a rate
of about 100 stores per year.
And when an economic
downturn hits, it thrives.
- It's about simplicity,
and it's about efficiency,
and it's about a consistent
experience all the time.
- [Narrator] This is
"The Economics of Aldi."
So how does the company
keep its prices so low?
Take its store set up.
- You walk in,
and the moment you step foot in our store,
you can see all four walls.
- [Narrator] Aldi's are typically
around 12,000 square feet,
about the same as a Trader Joe's,
and much smaller than
the average supermarket.
Operating a smaller space
saves money when buying the property
on the lease and on utilities.
- The layout at Aldi is as much designed
for our operational
efficiency as anything.
And so being very specific
about the amount of footsteps
it takes to service our store
and a very limited store size
allows us to operate a
very efficient operation,
and that creates a lot of value.
- [Narrator] To further its efficiency,
Aldi doesn't have extra services
like a customer help desk,
a fresh bakery, or butcher,
and its stocks significantly
fewer products.
Supermarkets typically carry
around 31,000 products.
Trader Joe's has about 4,000,
but Aldi stocks about 1,600.
Often, there are just
three to five employees
on the sales floor,
so having fewer items
and leaving them in the
boxes they were delivered in
means employees spend less
time stocking shelves.
These cost-cutting strategies
are critical to Aldi's profit margin,
and they're why the company
is able to offer items
that are cheaper than
the national average,
but they also serve another purpose.
They help maintain Aldi's
image as a discount store.
Customers make compensatory inferences.
Basically, marketing experts say
"When people see an item's price,
they quickly make assumptions
about the product.
If it's cheap, they may
assume it's lower quality,
which is why Aldi's no frill
strategy is so effective."
From the moment customers
put quarters in their carts
and walk into the store,
they can see all the
ways Aldi reduces costs.
Marketing experts say,
"These tactics all signal to the customer
that milk, eggs, and
bread are cheaper at Aldi
because of its efficiency
rather than its quality,
though, the results of its
cost-cutting strategies
aren't always popular with customers.
In a survey of roughly 6,500 people,
Aldi scored on par with,
or slightly lower than many of its peers
in categories like store
cleanliness and item availability.
But there's another key tactic grocers use
to aid their low-cost
images, Known Value Items.
These are staple household products
whose prices people often remember.
As Aldi has expanded across the country,
other grocers have reduced
their prices in response,
particularly on these types of items.
- When Aldi comes in,
it prompts other retailers
to look at their prices again
and kind of, you know, surgically examine
how to adjust what they
sell and for how much.
- [Narrator] That's because
when people see lower prices
for staple goods,
they infer that the business
offers low prices all around.
And when it comes to value for dollar,
Aldi ranked highest in the
customer survey at 96%,
but stores can only
compete on price so much
without hurting their profit margins.
So what does Aldi use
other than price point
to draw on customers?
It's private label items.
(can thudding)
90% of Aldi's stock is private label,
like its other strategies,
this reduces costs for the company.
- We take all of our buying power
and we put it into the seven most popular
or common salad dressings
that a customer might buy.
That allows us to deal
directly with manufacturers
and make sure that we
get the best cost price.
- [Narrator] Analysts say that,
Trader Joe's uses private-label items
to differ from competitors
by creating items
that customers can only find there,
like its Ube Mochi Pancake Mix,
and Butternut Squash Mac & Cheese.
But at Aldi, you'll
find private-label items
that look quite similar
to the most well-known national brands.
Instead of Wheat Thins,
Aldi has Thin Wheat.
According to analysts,
"This is because Aldi wants customers
to think they're essentially
getting the same product,
but at a significant discount."
- There was a time when
the perception was,
you know, they're a generic brand
and, you know, they're just cheaper,
but not as good as the national brands,
and those days are over.
- [Narrator] As consumers felt
the lasting impacts of inflation
sales of store brand products increased.
From 2018 to 2022,
there was a 34% increase in industry-wide
private label sales,
totaling more than $57 billion.
- While some other grocers
might have private label offerings,
this is the existence of what we do.
- [Narrator] Aldi has
thrived during recessions.
The 2008 Financial
Crisis sparked its growth
and decision to add around
100 new stores per year.
- What was really interesting is
we never lost any of those customers,
and as the economy improved
and we had a really long
run of economic improvement,
Aldi grew throughout that
entire period of time.
- [Narrator] And now as inflation
drains American's wallets,
Aldi continues to grow.
- In the beginning,
that was sort of their target audience,
people who, you know, wanted bargains,
and wanted to buy food for low prices.
But in recent years,
I think they've really
expanded that audience
to also go after people who
want convenient shopping,
who want the necessities,
and wanna be in and out of stores.
(playful music)